معك اسماعيل مجمع الشفاء ايضا تعرض للقصف
ما الذي ال اليه الوضع هناك بعد ما شهده
المجمع صحيح هذا المجمع الذي قصف بالامس
بثلاث غارات مختلفه ادت لسقوط ما يزيد عن
28 شهيدا ما زالت الامور صعبه في هذا
المكان في ظل تراكم عدد الاصابات الكبير
جدا بالاضافه الى صعوبه الوصول الى
المقابر علما ان علما ان الشهداء الذين
استشهدوا دفنوا داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
والساحه الخلفيه وهي المتنفس الوحيد لمجمع
الشفاء الطبي اصبحت مقبره جماعيه كبيره
يدفن بها الشهداء لكن على المستوى الطبي
والانساني الامور صعبه جدا ولا يتوفر
الكادر الطبي الكافي في داخل هذا المجمع
كما يعرف الجميع اصلا ان الكثير من
المعدات ايضا دمرت بعد دخول قوات الاحتلال
الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي بالاضافه انه
الكثير من المستلزمات الطبيه اصبحت هي في
احتياج كبير داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي بسبب
عدم دخول اي من المساعدات منذ 20 يوما سوى
نصف شاحنه وهي عباره عن ثلاث مشاطيح وفق
المصادر الطبيه ان هذه المستلزمات هي نقطه
في بحر الاحتياج الذي يحتاجه مستشفى
الشفاء اما على المستوى الميداني صراحه
يستمر القصف الاسرائيلي في مختلف انحاء
مدينه غزه فقد قصفت قوات الاحتلال مدرسه
امير المنسي التي تاوي النازحين ووقع هناك
سبعه شهداء وفق المصادر الطبيه وصلوا الى
مجمع شفاء الطبي علما ان هذه المدرسه كانت
محاصره بالامس يوم تتكشف الخيوط بعد وصول
المصادر من تلك الاماكن ووصول السكان
والنازحين من تلك الاماكن ل يطلعون على
الاخبار التي حصلت اكثر فقد قصفت قوات
الاحتلال صباح اليوم هذه المدرسه ووقع
هناك سبع شهداء بالاضافه الى قصف قوات
الاحتلال بقذيفه مدفعيه مجموعه من
المواطنين قرب مفترق الصناعه وسقط هناك
اربعه شهداء بعد غاره اسرائيليه على هؤلاء
المواطنين لكن الجريمه الاكبر وفق ما اخبر
بعض المواطنين ويصعب الوصول الى ذاك
المكان ووصل على العربات الكثير من
الشهداء من عائله سالم كانوا كانوا بداخل
عائله رمضان قرب كاظم وهذه العائله التي
نزحت من المناطق الشماليه الى المناطق
الغربيه لمدينه غزه فقد قامت قوات
الاحتلال بقصف المنزل الذي ياوي هذه
العائله باربعه صواريخ من طائرات الاف 35
مما ادى لسقوط كثيرا من الشهداء ووقوع
وبقي الكثير من الاصابات اسفل الركام ولا
تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه ولا طواقم الدفاع
المدني ولا اي من فرق الانقاذ الوصول الى
ذاك المكان لاجلاء السكان او المصابين
الذين بقوا اسفل هذا الركام